today's topic
[Music]
today we're out here having a pony play
competition
where people compete in events and
classes just the same as
real horses do just like a regular
horseshoe event we end up with
some crashes and racks
people go down over the dumps
the competition gets pretty crazy
sometimes
any thoughts well it's just a kink
essentially that's a kink that's none of
my business what they do
they grown folks and they're consenting
adults it's none of my business
what's up i just wish i could be a horse
watching them i wish i could get in the
mind of a horse just watch these people
go like
these [ __ ] coopers not only do they
ride us
but then they ride our image into the
ground could you imagine like trying to
like
play and imagine yourself as a horse
and having a small penis
you know i mean like if you've ever seen
horse [ __ ] it's ginormous so it would
just be kind of funny
it's about expressing your inner
personality too because so many
other people i'm sure i can speak for
live um
a life monday through friday that's not
really an expression of who they are
what they do it's what pays their bills
when you get a chance to come out here
and you get to
enjoy what you do and be around other
people who enjoy similar things and
enjoy it with them
it's a great feeling the freedom to be
weird yes
yes the freedom to be weird imagine
putting that on your tinder profile what
are you into
horses you're like oh cool what do you
mean you're into horses
i become one on the weekends
i think this is just what happens in the
first world country you know when
when all your basic needs are taken care
of and you're bored
all of a sudden you start looking at a
horse and you're just like maybe their
existence is more interesting you know
yeah it's like when you when you live in
a third world country you're struggling
every day you're not like
[Music]
right like that's a first world kind of
reaction to things right
i mean when you're struggling every day
is not part of your vocabulary the same
way when you struggle every day you ride
horses you don't go
so this is one of those things but this
channel is interesting
that will always be my favorite part all
of our outfits that we make
are based off of buy a horse equipment
or made out of buy a horse equipment
that's been rearranged
to fit humans and can get very costly
people are very proud of
their outfits you know the funny thing
is that people who do this kind of stuff
are some of the kindest and nicest
people
yeah there's a bad there's a bad
eye on king like it's weird and not
normal and people are psychotic and [ __ ]
like that
but it's not the case things are there's
a lot it's just we don't talk about it
we don't talk about it but
if there's a lot more people that have
kings than you think that's why i'm
saying that it's normal
it's part of the sexual world that's all
i'm saying you know
when we talk and when we talk about
normal a lot of people have
certain degrees of a king not to that
extent but
kings is a normal thing
everything on me is custom made my ears
are made from old boots and then i have
some fox fur for make a little bit fuzzy
kind of get that shetland look the
muzzle is custom made from a friend
named daisy doll
you know i got my my bit and everything
here uh custom made the bridge which is
a
french braid but uh the suit i did
custom make you know added
the markings and everything to give me
more of that that shetland breed look
guys this is why we need prostitution
there's people who are into stuff like
this who have husbands and wives who
will never reciprocate
sometimes you got to find people who
want to be into what you're into
because you could tell these people they
feel great you know they feel in their
natural habitat and i support it and
underneath this
this particular harness that i'm wearing
now uh
it's not really meant for pulling carts
or anything its only purpose
is to hold my tail because my tail is
five pounds by itself
which is quite a bit of weight so you
know that's
what it's about i love you you're my
favorite choice
[Music]
the tack as the the pony equipment is
called
is a very essential part for most
counties but it's also very important to
adopting that role and being able to
change
from the human aspect to the pony aspect
in a headspace kind of way like really
get into character right so looking the
part is
a big part of playing the part yes and
when it comes to ponytack it's a lot
about individual expression
yeah everybody's a little different yeah
sometimes you start out with uh
ears and a tail in the end here
yes it's a i don't want to say it's a
one-way road but it's definitely a hole
once you get into it it's a slippery
road it's a slippery road
yeah we're gonna make
upright tax paying citizens monday
through friday so
to get to go out and pretend to be
something else
for the weekend is like so much fun
what do you think it's like for them
when they go back to work on monday and
everyone knows what they do on the
weekend
well they keep it the most people
they're gonna keep it on the low they're
not gonna go and about
and tell everybody because of how
they're gonna look so they just go back
to normal and stuff like that you know i
mean it's like
whenever i used to battle dance battle i
didn't necessarily tell all
the every place i go tell my coworkers
because they wouldn't get it
and i'd get some dumb questions and i
don't
want to have to i'm at work taking calls
i don't want necessarily to have to
explain myself on what i did on the
weekend
and have i mean just playing like that
also you battle people so what there's
violence
shut up diane so so what you guys
uh battle and you have different crews
yeah so is that gang related
shut the [ __ ] up suzanne like you don't
want to answer dumb ass questions you
know
it ain't that deep so it's not it's not
that much of a problem so be
most of the time keep themselves keep
keep it to themselves just not to have
to face
and to explain themselves while they're
at work
answering calls you know what i mean
yeah 100 i get what you're saying
if i find out if somebody was into this
pony stuff at work i believe
okay and i would go about what i know it
would be
gossip in a lot of places in fact
you wouldn't even be able to keep a job
in certain places if you were no and
especially if
especially if you're not hurting anybody
consensual people and stuff like that
and they're doing their thing
that yeah it's none of our business
so imagine you're losing your job for
[ __ ] like that that
he's a maniac he's this and he's that
which to be fair though
if i'm hiring the lawyer and he's like
i'll fight for you i'll catch you and
then i see him on the weekend he's
getting muzzled and dragged around
of course i might be like i don't think
this is the [ __ ] that i want uh
fighting for my company
yeah do whatever the [ __ ] you want on
the weekend
what what what if what if the
prosecution shows up to court
with the horse whip
what does that have to do with anything
what if there's a watch and all of a
sudden
your your lawyer went from your honor to
you know what if there's an instinctual
it's not a trigger it's
it's not how it works and that's the
kind of dumb questions that i don't want
to face at work
hey i'm just saying i'm just saying i'm
just saying so if i
if i go are you going to get hard that's
the kind of dumb questions they don't
want to hear at work
but they don't talk about it hey hey
listen i'm just i'm just saying
imagine you go to work and then and you
go to work and then suzanne
from accounting is like oh um
abba i've seen a good dance movie uh it
was really dope
magic mike and you're like that's not
what i do that's not what i took suzanne
shut up okay yeah but you dance right i
saw magic mike that's
that's dope and you're like
i wonder if white people ever feel some
type of when they just see these kind of
videos and it's always white folks who
do these weird kicks
i can assure you that it's not just
white folks oh go on tell us more
like i said like on on the french side i
have a i have a sexual podcast so
a podcast on sex right so we we we visit
these different uh things and we visited
not too long ago i was in a dungeon
filming a podcast an episode an episode
and we were filming
we were explaining the person was
explaining us what was in the dungeon
you know i mean what was happening in
the dungeon
and we're not talking about 50 shade of
grey that's fake that's not
that's not real bdsm so we we had we we
had a real
uh mistress and she was explaining us
what was going on
let me ask you a question when you were
in that dungeon
as a black man yup that's the first
thing i said
i'm not i'm not you're not gonna attach
me you're not gonna whip me
feel like you didn't feel like your
ancestors your ancestors
we didn't do anything but like we didn't
try anything or anything like that but
i'm like
we had i had that reflection i'm like yo
there's no way there is no way
that you're putting end cuffs on me but
i got ptsd
i got ptsd from that [ __ ] but there is
no way that you're
whipping me fewer but there still is but
i like yeah
my connect my connotation with whipping
is different than other people that
didn't live too what do you think is the
correlation between black men who love
um handcuffs and the odds of their
girlfriends being white do you think
there's like a strong correlation
between those two things
i don't know and i don't think so i
don't know i don't think so
but me we wouldn't know
i don't know i'm just saying if i'm
gonna have a slave master fantasy
i probably would need a white girl there
i've heard yeah i've heard about it yeah
i've definitely heard about it because
you're doing great
play with a black girl it feels
different you know what i'm saying yeah
people that i have letter that i
received in my podcast and stuff like
that
of the year we talk about different [ __ ]
and then yeah this so yeah it happens
so that's why i'm not i'm not irked by
any kinks i'm not like
we've we spoke about that i've had that
that
that podcast for like a little while now
so that's why i was like
i know this geek i know what that is i'm
not irked by i understand what it is
i've seen it and i've got it i have
people explaining it to me and
what we what we see in the media as bdsm
is of course even it's not what it is
it's not the reality of what it is
you know what this is to me it's not
it's not something that irks me it's
just
it's like going to the circus and
watching the person do
you know the whole bending to like i'm
like this is weird it's gross
it's okay doesn't have to like when i
watch a girl bend her leg behind her
back
and start walking like a thing out of
the movie it and she's like
you know when i see that like it's the
same thing with this
right as all of this so when i see the
girl with the leg behind her leg
or her head i'm like oh
it doesn't hurt me at all you know
what's funny i watched a video a long
time ago called mr hands you ever heard
of it
mr hand mr hands there's a bunch of
people right now watching on youtube who
know exactly what i'm talking about
pants hands plural like hands yes
you'll put it on no no no no no this
can't go on youtube
it's not one of those videos this is
this is a video for your podcast okay
but anyways in this video the the man
goes to his favorite horse ranch and
gets uh
basically impaled by a horse and he dies
right okay no i can't put that on mine i
can't put that on
it but the video is called mr hands it's
actually a news thing that came out
where it's like
the hold up man dies from horse
experience
is that if that's a term yeah yeah but
anyways if you guys want you guys can go
look at mr hands yourself i do not
recommend it
it is short but disturbing yeah don't
watch it
yeah now i know a bunch of people did it
for research purposes well you did that
for research purposes anyways leave your
comments below let us know what you
think
[Music]
ah
oh